こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです
今日はちょっとしたお知らせがまずあります
僕がプロデュースして、
その形とかを考えた、
木琴が発売されま～す
めっちゃくっちゃ音が良くて使いやすいです
こちらの木琴　49800円で販売されております
みんなさんぜひ下のリンクから買ってみてください
ウソですｗｗｗ
この動画をどういうテンション出来ればいいのか
いまいち分かっていないんだが
もやししゃちょーがリリースされました～
いやいや
もう作ってくださった方　ありがとうございました　なんですけど
なっ、なんなんだろ、このなんか
俺の腑に落ちない感じ～
とりあえず、やってみましょう...
俺はどう、あ、も～
このほらも～
このダウンローディングの顔が出してちょっと
なんなんですか！？
あ～い　もやししゃちょーとういう事で
お話しを聞く限り
なんかシンプルなんですけど
すっごいみんな楽しい楽しいって言ってくださってありがとうございます
いや、面白いのは良い事だよ
面白いのは良い事だけどさ
もやししゃちょー…
とういう訳で　ちょっと早速やってみましょう！
あっ、俺だ
俺はいつも通り、実験動画を撮影していた
すると突然！
顔！顔！
BANG！
実験に失敗し、爆発してしまったのだ...
あらららら...
しばらくの間に気絶していたが
ちょっと待ってよｗｗ
とんでもない姿に
お～い
腕が...
ない！
足もない
俺もやしの形してるじゃん！
なんてこったああああああああ！
このなんか うまいっすよねｗｗ
僕の髪の毛にね、もやしを埋め込んでる、
このディティールとかすごいんすよね
なんで俺はもやしの姿に！
クオリティたけぇなwww
どうやらはじめしゃちょーはもやしの姿になってしまった...
見ればわかるわ！
もやし姿のはじめしゃちょー、通称もやししゃちょーを育てて、
収穫するとっても素敵なゲームだ
まずはソコに生えているのもシュッと抜いてみて
お～～～～い！
これはどんな顔してやれゃんだ？このゲームを
もやししゃちょー...新もやし発見！
実験に失敗して体がもやしになったはじめ
バスケとドッキリが得意だったが、
いまはただ水分を補給するだけの存在に
リアルだね～
これ大丈夫ですか？みんな鳥肌立たないかな？
ホラーでしょ、も～これ
きりふきで地面も濡らせば早く生えてるみたいですね
うわあぁぁ
うお！
ホラーだから
めっちゃくっちゃだよ～なん、なん
ちょっと待ってｗｗ
あのこれね～
みんなにはわかんないだろうね、俺の気持ちが
作られた本人俺どんな顔してこのゲームをやればいいか
すごい今、複雑な心境に堕ちっております
おっ！これは！
顔！
屈託のねぇ～笑顔だな　チクショ～
こういう感じでですね、
いろんなもやししゃちょーがどんどん出て来るらしいです…
もう次のステージに行けるようになった！
ステージがどんどん進んでくるんっすね
なんで俺がいっぱい生えてきてるんだ？偽物は消えてくれ！
顔！
うわっ！びっくりした！誰だお前！？
お前こそ誰だ！？俺こそが本物のはじめだぞ！
ちなみになんですけど
これね　あの
あのレジェンドもやしって言われるガチャみたいな機能がありまして
隠れもやししゃちょーがいるらしいです
一回購入してみよう
マジか俺課金すんのか
120円で一回できる
すげぇな　ほい
出たーーー！
ドラゴンはじめ！
はじめの中二病精神が具現化したドラゴン
立派な翼は見掛け倒しなので、飛べない
おい！
まぁ　七種類いろんなドラゴン(もやし)がいるので
ぜひみんなさんガツガツ課金してください
ちなみにこれですね　あの
はじめ兄さんの時はですね　僕が色々こう携わってて
このもやししゃちょーに関しては僕ノータッチなんで
僕もどんなキャラがいるがわかんないです
魔王はじめ
圧倒的な魔力で暗黒もやし界を牛耳る王様
と言い張る自分大好きなはじめ
趣味はボランティア
はい！とういう訳でもやししゃちょー
とっても僕は複雑な気分なのですが
なかなか楽しめそうでございます
たくさんのもやししゃちょーがいるので　みんなさん　ぜひ
暇なときスルスルスルっとするだけでできるので　やってみてください！
ではみんなさん　よい週末を　じゃあな